مسلسل مغربي جديد يعرض على منصه شاهد في
اي بي كاول اعمال شاهد الاصليه المغربيه
المسلسل يروي قصه ثلاثه اطفال من اطفال
الشوارع يعملون في ازقه الدار البيضاء
على حقيبه مليئه بالمال ينضم لنا في
الاستوديو يوسف زين الدين من فريق شاهد
يوسف اهلا بك يسعد صباحكم منور
شاهد الاصليه المغربيه
الدار البيضاء قصه المسلسل زي ما حكيت قبل
شويه عم بتسللط الضوء على اطفال الشوارع
وكل الصعوبات والتحديات اللي بوجهها وفي
ناس يعني قررت احنا ما بدنا نحرق كثير
قررت انها تطلع من بيت اهلها لانها ما
كانت مبسوطه
تتعرض ل مع اسى بي الشارع وكيف في ناس
تستغل هذول الاطفال باتجاهات مختلفه فعم
نشوف احنا قصص واقعيه بقدر احكي لك يعني
تم دراسه قصص واقعيه موجوده في الشارع
المغربي وتم طبعا صيغتها بي سياق دراما
وعم نشوفها طبعا المسلسل طيب يوسف كمان
لاحظنا في ترجمه سب تايتنز تحت قد ايه
كمان هذا مهم واضافه في اعمال شاهد انه
حتى الاعمال العربيه ولكن على اختلاف
اللهجات في ترجمه طبيعي لانه بتعرفي نادين
بعض المصطلحات احنا بيننا وبين بعض قد ما
نفهمها فاليوم انت بترجع بتقدري عشان
تقدري توصل الى اللغه اسرع لانه في بعض
المصطلحات بالمغرب ممكن احنا همم
دائما همم
الترجمه للكلمات بتكون اسهل لالي معانا عم
باجي بحضر عشان ما اقضي عليك كلمه او شيء
ممكن تكون مهمه في سياق الحدث افلام
ومسلسلات مغربيه في شاهد اليوم هذا كازا
ستريت من اعمال شاهد الاصليه اولا كيف
شفتوا على شاهد الاقبال عن الافلام
المغربيه شوفي كان في عنا اقباله عنا عدد
مشتركين من بدنا نحكي شمال افريقيا همم لا
باس به يعني عدد جميل ومتفاعلين فاحنا
حبينا انه كهديه وكبدايه تكون وجود هذا
العمل المغربي وراح يكون ان شاء الله نعمل
جزائري ان شاء الله قريبا ف- همم يعني
بتعرفي من الاعمى يعني نحن دائما بنحاول
انه يعني المحيط للخليج اعمالنا دائما
حاول انه يكون فيها عنا اعمال تغطي كافه
الفئات
همم كمان خلينا نحكي يوسف انه لانه في
برنامج زد رصيدك هذا البرنامج يعود بموسمه
الثامن على منصه شهده برنامج تلفزيون
الواقع ياخذ فيه مجموعه من الشباب من جميع
انحاء السعوديه تحدي لمده 90 يوما وبرهن
انه مستعدون للفعل كل ما بوسعهم لتحقيق
احلامهم
[موسيقى]
زد رصيدك القصه على شاهد مجانا ابطال
القصه متسابقين يركبون خلف تحقيق احلامهم
ولكن الثمن باهض
90 ليله هنعيشها داخل اسوار القريه
معزولين تماما عن العالم الخارجي
16 ساعه ما يوميا على خط واحد والحظور
متساوي
على شاهد مجد
البرنامج زد رصيدك من البرامج فعلا
الجميله هو مستمر
سابقه ولكن هذا الموسم موجود على شاهد
المجاني الجميع بقدر يستمتعوا انه يحضر
هذا البرنامج برنامج نقدر نحكي من تلفزيون
الواقع راح نعيش مع المشتركين 16 ساعه
يوميا عبر منصه شاهد من الساعه 9:00 الصبح
لغايه المساء هنشوفهم عايشين في بيت واحد
عم بيصير في تحديات بس ولكن الفكره
الاساسيه هي جميع المال وزياده الرصيد
يعني كل شخص عنده فكره بيت بناء مشروع او
في يعني مشاريعهم وتخطيط لهذه المشاريع
وكيف تم انه انا ادرس هاي المشاريع معه
مختصين هنشوفها كلها بالبرنامج بالاضافه
لا فقرات ترفيهيه راح يكون في عندنا فقرات
متنوعه بين الطبخ بين ال- همم بيت الحكمه
وغيرها راح يكون في بيو يعني في فقرات
متنوعه هنشوف هنروح نستمتع ومش بس هيك
كمان راح يكون في ضيوف طبعا هنشوفهم
عن البيئه الحلقات القادمه مشاهير راح
يكونوا موجودين يزوروا المقر فا يعني
اتوقع من البرامج الجميله اللي هتعلمنا
احنا كمان كيف نزيد رصيد
ك في اليوم بس على كم يعني
راحت عن بالي بس هي نحكي لك 10 ايام اول
10 ايام هلا بدا هو من كم يوم اول 10 ايام
راح يتم فيها تحديد الاختبارات وبعد 10
ايام راح يكون في النونانيه او اللي هم
اختيار المرشحين للاقصاء فبعدها راح تصير
شخص يطلع من البرنامج
اللي بيحصل على اعلى نسبه من الاربعه والى
اما ده الشاهد تراهن على هيك برامج
شوفي ليه احنا عندنا هيك برامج لانه زي ما
كان شكرا بنحكي عن التنوع اللي موجود
دائما انت دكتور وفي كثير ناس بتحب برامج
عم بتصير بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه من
التصوير
وتكبير المشاريع احنا عم نشوف هذا
البرنامج عم بساعد الشباب على انهم يساهم
او التطويرها بدنا نحكي بشكل اكبر وانا
هلا بشكل عم بحكي لك انه عم يساعدنا احنا
كمان كمشاهدين بالافكار لانه في عندهم
مختصين وهم كمان عندهم افكارهم نادر احنا
نطبقها بحياتنا
[موسيقى]
للمشاهدين الله يزيد رصيدنا في الحياه وفي
الحب وفي العمل وفي الماده وفي الصحه وفي
كل شيء
والى هنا ينتهي حديثنا معك ولكن الحديث
تتم شكرا